hello world on TV Sinclair here again
with you boy Shack what up and today
we're gonna check out the new trapper
Jack yeah Dave Jack is the new trapper
coming to you straight in hunting season
two first we had Lennox the assault and
now we have Jack and he is a brawler
type trapper perfect for these arena
situations he's a smart little
whippersnapper who makes his own tools
out of the wreckage of share and you
know he occasionally also likes to see
himself as a superhero the jackal yes
the jackal is his alternate persona so
oftentimes you'll uh you'll probably
mostly get the jackal out of Jack and
he's a he's either he's a kooky little
guy but we love him you know he's a he's
a scrapper and that's why we like to
play with Jack sometimes his teammates
feel differently but Shaq we do love him
here we love his dialog can't wait for
you guys to hear that you could see him
using the repulsor there and going into
the pistols the idea with his pistols
that is that he recharges one set while
using the other set this makes reloads a
lot faster and keep you shooting yeah
Dave so he's got two sets of dual
pistols that's cool add him up that's
four pistols or pistol or pistols so
your fire into while the two are firing
the other two are recharging in your
pockets they do look differently they
shoot slightly differently but you're
going to be able to do the same damage
at the same speed with both sets so very
cool very unique to this guy and what's
also super cool is while he's firing
those pistols he is moving at full
movement speed so he's the only hunter
who can maintain that quick fast
movement speed while firing his water
bang-bang Goliath you saw jack using his
repulsor there the repulsor is sort of
like a negative harpoon it was
originally used to blow cargo but now
the repulsor applies of pushing a
resistance force to the monsters which
could push the monster away from you or
your teammates yeah Dave I think this is
probably the coolest piece of equipment
a hunter could have let alone a trapper
it's almost like he's got the force with
him Dave he's pushing the monster away
from teammates he's pushing the monster
away from himself
look at that the blog the leap smash
that is the repulsor that is textbook so
what happens is what it turns green
that's when it's actually consuming ammo
and when the monster uses more abilities
that's how do you how it hits it's
recharged quicker also what's cool is
got different uses for different
monsters so for a Kraken you can push
the Kraken down to the ground by pushing
it on top or if the Krakens about to
drop down and drop an aftershock on you
you can keep them in the air so super
versatile and really changes the game
yeah as you mentioned the beam can be
bent to apply resistance that angles up
to 90 degrees so you can hit that Kraken
from above you could push that behemoth
back and then you could switch your guns
and bang bang bang in the face all right
Dave so this third piece of equipment
which is super cool is the satellite now
the satellite is taken from a satellite
on shear it's been repurposed and a
plantable device so what it does is it
puts out green survey beams in an area
around the monster and when it finds the
monster actually does damage so it
highlights footsteps and highlights
recently killed carcasses and most
importantly it highlights the big
battery life and it scans a hundred
meter radius and highlights the freshest
tracks wildlife corpses left by the
monster and as you mentioned it does do
damage one thing that the monster can do
is try to counter that by moving his way
in and out of the beams but if you use
that repulsor and timing with the survey
satellite you can lock that monster in
the beam and do the most amount of
damage possible yeah Dave so this team
yet again is putting up a really good
fight against this Goliath I like I like
what's going on here jack is really a
scrapper and I've I've been saying that
a lot and and I mean it you know when
you compare him with Lennox to very
in-your-face characters that are coming
in this this hunting season - it's
really exciting you know turning taking
the trapper turning it on its head a
perfect carrot amusing
which is as you know my favorite mode I
love to brawl I love to get in there
with the hunters as Goliath and you know
Jack has made me change my place outlet
full time yeah he's a lot of fun to play
with and we absolutely cannot wait to
get him in your hands as you can see the
hunters looking to finish off the
gliders here Jackie huge part of that
because he's not only keeping the damage
off of the hunters he's helping them do
damage towards the monster as well can't
wait to see what you guys do with Jack
and his repulsor a lot of really cool
ways to use the device and you know
we're probably gonna discover a ton more
as this goes live we're super stoked for
everyone to get their hands on it and
looks like this team is about to
vanquish this Goliath yet again so that
was Jack everyone check him out in the
next update for hunting season 2 I'm
your boy Jack I'm DB and that was Jack
you